haddock il est pas hétérosexuels alors
les chéri j'ai la boite à bukavu merci
et merci
oh là là à une rumeur d'hier et alors je
vous jure je sais pas qui a mis ça
j'aime j'aime découvrir dirais que
benjamin castaldi aurait de faux
pectoraux et de faux abdou n'diaye est
ce que c'est vrai alors c'est
entièrement faux dur le bas la mer vous
voulez toucher jeu rien les frères qui
se déshabillent attend c'est pas mal on
fait pas mal là là bas salaires vrai
l'epec barge pour de vrai en une semaine
amani a un énorme coup de coeur pour
quelqu un coup de coeur s'est calmée
elle a un coup de coeur pour quelqu'un
une évidence tant à manille mais
quelqu'un dit si oui non non c'est le
cas du viiie arrondissement
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu un coup de coeur pour lui donc
écoute là s'il te plaît parce que les
d'été des coutelas est pas coutume afin
d'avoir tous les ans après donc tu
écouteras il ya quelqu'un qui te kiffe
là mais j'ai j'ai trop aimé le fait que
doc gynéco en fait s'il allait se
balader à un mètre je pense à m il
allait se balader dans les rues à côté
des petits magasins et où ils étaient en
train de distribuer des de l'argent non
ouais pour à des mendiants jeu rude pour
des personnes qui l'avaient senti je
vais pas les personnes ont besoin
d'argent et c'était juste la crise et où
at-il jolie sienna doc a par contre là
je vais tout casser parce que les docks
à fantasmer sur francesca tout le
week-end
non non ça c'est pas fouet c'est pas
faux ça va vous les coupables non mais
ça arrive donc c'est vrai non j'ai passé
un petit moment avec elle elle était
seule isolée du périgord on a passé tout
le temps ce qu'il aimait bien tu l'aimé
bien assez serrée demain tu as envie de
la voir demain ouais hein
il est content a est une attelle à cliff
ou pas well est sympa bah ouais les
allemands sont hostiles et même très
ravissante c'est qu'il a fait préférer
dans tpm paix même si l'outil par un
mois moi je crois savoir moi et bien à
mes yeux valérie est une star faut
qu'elle reste comme elle est celle reste
comme année pour moi c'est comme si elle
est énorme à cet âge-là changera plus et
s'il vous plaît si ces deux maps les
bébés les gens voient c'est un support
que les téléspectateurs nous avons c'est
bref oui bon alors amour je venais maps
et cyril j'ai fait il met son baba un
patron d'accor à les patrons c'est hyper
malaisie gsm à bas les images je voulais
juste dire quelque chose peut être
voulez vous rendre hommage avec le
hashtag je n'ai pas vu sur twitter je
préférais vous le dire en vrai les trois
jours vous n'étiez pas là et on n'était
pas ensemble en tunisie du coup j'ai
couché qu'une personne et j'ai cherché
longtemps longtemps pour avoir sincérité
non oui c'est un échec ainsi ring pas
très très beau mais je voulais le prénom
de j'ai couché avec d'autres séries l'on
veut rendre au match
ah ouais la tunisie est alors un
tunisien à la tunisie ne bat n'étaient
pas tunisien côté je pouvais pas tout
faire y avait pas eu ces panoplies
millionnaire j'ai pris ce qu'ils avaient
bon voyage
bref cyril alors là c'est mignon comme
s'en est rendu compte de quoi bas que
c'était pas le le cirill du cirill je
disais cyril mais je pensais cyril à web
alors vous ne pensez plus indique cyril
et penser jean-marc allez vous le dire
ou jean-michel j'en attends tu m'avais
dit déjà plus cher ou docu un ado qu'il
ait pas hétérosexuels
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]